people ask me so are you guys going to
do another one you know I we could be on
jackass 27 they'll be like so what's up
with 28 sure my answer is always I just
can't imagine it happening but don't
take my word for it because I would have
said the same thing about a jackass 4
for 10 years to go by with no jackass
and all of a sudden you reach out and
say guys I'm ready to go again I know
that's happened on the last two like on
jck S4 I started getting that Twitchy
feeling that I wanted to do it again and
then we were around 20
8ish or 9ish and I just started watching
so much Tom and Jerry again and I
started getting that feeling that's what
inspired you Tom and Jerry well I just
knew that I was trying to think of ideas
and Jeff we had a desk right across from
each other and I think you would see Tom
and Jerry and he's like put two and two
together finally I said I wanted to do
another one and he was so shocked